Okay.
This is a lecture where
complex numbers come in.
It's a -- complex numbers
have slipped into this course
because even a real matrix
can have complex eigenvalues.
So we met complex numbers
there as the eigenvalues
and complex eigenvectors.
And we -- or --
this is probably the last --
we have a lot of other things
to do about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
And that will be mostly real.
But at one point
somewhere, we have
to see what you do when the
numbers become complex numbers.
What happens when the
vectors are complex,
when the matrixes are
complex, when the --
what's the inner product of two,
the dot product of two complex
vectors --
we just have to make
the change, just see --
what is the change when
numbers become complex?
Then, can I tell you about
the most important example
of complex matrixes?
It comes in the Fourier matrix.
So the Fourier matrix,
which I'll describe,
is a complex matrix.
It's certainly the most
important complex matrix.
It's the matrix that we
need in Fourier transform.
And the -- really, the special
thing that I want to tell you
about is what's called the
fast Fourier transform,
and everybody refers to it
as the FFT and it's in all
computer and it's used --
it's being used as we
speak in a thousand places,
because it has, like,
transformed whole industries
to be able to do the
Fourier transform fast,
which means multiplying --
how do I multiply fast by that
matrix -- by that n by n matrix?
Normally, multiplications
by an n by n matrix --
would normally be n
squared multiplications,
because I've got n squared
entries and none of them is
zero.
This is a full matrix.
And it's a matrix with
orthogonal columns.
I mean, it's just,
like, the best matrix.
And this fast Fourier
transform idea
reduces this n squared,
which was slowing up
the calculation of Fourier
transforms down to n log(n).
n log(n), log to the
base two, actually.
And it's this --
when that hit --
when that possibility hit,
it made a big difference.
Everybody realized
gradually what, --
that this simple idea -- you'll
see it's just a simple matrix
factorization -- but
it changed everything.
Okay.
So I want to talk about
complex vectors and matrixes
in general, recap a
little bit from last time,
and the Fourier
matrix in particular.
Okay.
So what's the deal?
All right.
The main point is,
what about length?
I'm given a vector,
I have a vector x.
Or let me call it z as a
reminder that it's complex,
for the moment.
But I can -- later I'll
call the components x.
They'll be complex numbers.
But it's a vector --
z1, z2 down to zn.
So the only novelty is
it's not in R^n anymore.
It's in complex n
dimensional space.
Each of those numbers
is a complex number.
So this z,z1 is in C^n, n
dimensional complex space
instead of R^n.
So just a different letter
there, but now the point
about its length is what?
The point about its length is
that z transpose z is no good.
z transpose z -- if I just
put down z transpose here,
it would be z1, z2, to zn.
Doing that multiplication
doesn't give me
the right thing.
W-Why not?
Because the length squared
should be positive.
And if I multiply -- suppose
this is, like, 1 and i.
What's the length of the
vector with components 1 and i?
What if I do this,
so n is just two.
I'm in C^2, two
dimensional space,
complex space with the vector
whose components are 1 and i.
All right.
So if I took one times one
and i times i and added,
z transpose z would be zero.
But I don't -- that
vector is not --
doesn't have length zero -- the
vector with the components 1
and i --
this multiplication -- what I
really want is z1 conjugate z1.
You remember that z1
conjugate z1 is --
so you see that first step
will be z1 conjugate z1,
which is the magnitude of z1
squared, which is what I want.
That's, like, three
squared or five squared.
Now, if it's -- if z1 is i, then
I multiplied by minus i gives
one plus one, so the component
of length -- the component i,
its modulus squared is plus
one.
That's great.
So what I want to do
then is do that --
I want z1 bar z1, z2
bar z2, zn bar zn.
And remember that -- you
remember this complex
conjugate.
So -- so there's the point.
Now I can erase
the no good and put
is good, because that now gives
the answer zero for the zero
vector, of course, but it
gives a positive length
squared for any other vector.
So it's a -- it's the
right definition of length,
and essentially the message is
that we're always going to be
taking --
when we transpose, we also
take complex conjugate.
So let's -- let's find
the length of one --
so the vector one i, that's
z, that's that vector z.
Now I take the conjugate of one
is one, the conjugate of i is
minus i.
I take this vector,
I get one plus one --
I get
two.
So that's a vector and that's a
vector of length -- square root
of two.
Square root of two is the
length and not the zero
that we would have got
from one minus i squared.
Okay.
So the message really is
whenever we transpose,
we also take conjugates.
So here's a symbol --
one symbol to do both.
So that symbol H, it stands
for a guy named Hermite,
who didn't actually
pronounce the H,
but let's pronounce it --
so I would call
that z Hermitian z.
I'll -- let me write that word,
Herm- so his name was Hermite,
and then we make it into
an adjective, Hermitian.
So z Hermitian z. z H z.
Okay.
So, that's the --
that's the, length squared.
Now what's the inner product?
Well, it should match.
The inner product
of two vectors --
so inner product is no longer --
used to be y transpose x.
That's for real vectors.
For complex vectors,
whenever we transpose,
we also take the conjugate.
So it's y Hermitian x.
Of course it's not
real anymore, usually.
That -- the inner product will
usually be complex number.
But if y and x are the
same, if they're the same z,
then we have z -- z H z,
we have the length squared,
and that's what we want, the
inner product of a vector with
itself should be
its length squared.
So this is, like, forced on us
because this is forced on us.
So -- so this z -- this --
everybody's picking
up what this equals.
This is z1 squared
plus zn squared.
That's the length squared.
And that's the inner product
that we have to go with.
So it could be a
complex number now.
One more change.
Well, two more changes.
We've got to change the
idea of a symmetric matrix.
So I'll just recap on
symmetric matrixes.
Symmetric means A transpose
equals A, but not --
no good if A is complex.
So what do we instead --
that applies perfectly
to real matrixes.
But now if my
matrixes were complex,
I want to take the transpose
and the conjugate to equal A.
So there's -- that's the --
the right complex version
of symmetry.
The com- the symmetry
now means when
I transpose it, flip across the
diagonal and take conjugates.
So, for example -- here
would be an example.
On the diagonal, it
had better be real,
because when I flip it, the
diagonal is still there and it
has to -- and then when I take
the complex conjugate it has
to be still there, so it
better be a real number,
let me say two and five.
What about entries
off the diagonal?
If this entry is,
say, three plus i,
then this entry had better be --
because I want whatever
this -- when I transpose,
it'll show up here
and i conjugate.
So I need three minus I there.
So there's a matrix with --
that corresponds to
symmetry, but it's complex.
And those matrixes are
called Hermitian matrixes.
Hermitian matrixes.
A H equals A.
Fine.
Okay, that's -- and those
matrixes have real eigenvalues
and they have
perpendicular eigenvectors.
What does perpendicular mean?
Perpendicular means
the inner product --
so let's go on to perpendicular.
Well, when I had perpendicular
vectors, for example,
they were like q1, q2 up to qn.
That's my -- q is my letter
that I use for perpendicular.
Actually, I usually --
I also mean unit length.
So those are perpendicular
unit vectors.
But now what does
-- so it's a --
orthonormal basis, I'll
still use those words,
but how do I compute
perpendicular?
How do I check perpendicular?
This means that the inner
product of qi with qj --
but now I not only transpose,
I must conjugate, right,
to get zero if i is not
j and one if i is j.
So it's a unit vector, meaning
unit length, orthogonal --
all the angles are right
angles, but these are angles
in complex n dimensional space.
So it's q1, q on-
qi bar transpose.
Or, for short, qi H qj.
So it will still be
true -- so let me --
again I'll create a
matrix out of those guys.
The matrix will have these
q-s in its columns, q2 to qn.
And I want to turn that
into matrix language,
just like before.
What does that mean?
That means I want all
these inner products,
so I take these columns of
Q, multiply by their rows --
so it was -- it used to be Q
-- it used to be Q transpose Q
equals I, right?
This was an orthogonal matrix.
But what's changed?
These are now complex vectors.
Their inner products are --
involve conjugating the first
factor.
So it's not -- it's the
conjugate of Q transpose.
It's Q bar transpose Q.
Q H.
So can I call this -- let me
call it Q H Q, which is I.
So that's our new --
you -- you see I'm just
translating, and the --
the book h- on one page gives a
little dictionary of the right
words in the real case, R^n,
and the corresponding words
in the complex case for
the vector space C^n.
Of course, C^n is
a vector space,
the numbers we multiply
are now complex numbers --
we're just moving into
complex n dimensional space.
Okay.
Now -- actually, I have to say
we changed the word symmet-
symmetric to Hermitian
for those matrixes.
People also change this word
orthogonal into another word
that happens to be unitary,
as a word that applies --
that signals that we might be
dealing with a complex matrix
here.
So what's a unitary matrix?
It's a -- it's just like
an orthogonal matrix.
It's a square, n by n matrix
with orthonormal columns,
perpendicular columns,
unit vectors --
unit vectors computed by --
and perpendicularity computed
by remembering that
there's a conjugate as well
as a transpose.
Okay.
So those are the words.
Now I'm ready to get into the
substance of the lecture which
is the most famous complex
matrix, which happens
to be one of these guys.
It has orthogonal columns,
and it's named after Fourier
because it comes into
the Fourier transform,
so it's the matrix
that's all around us.
Okay.
Let me tell you what it is
first of all in the n by n case.
Then often I'll let n be four
because four is a good size
to work with.
But here's the n by
n Fourier matrix.
Its first column is
the vector of ones.
It's n by n, of course.
Its second column is
the powers, the --
actually, better if I move
from the math department
to EE for this one half
hour and then, please,
let me move back again.
Okay.
What's the difference between
those two departments?
It's just math starts
counting with one
and electrical engineers
start counting at zero.
Actually, they're
probably right.
So anyway, we'll give
them -- humor them.
So this is really
the zeroes column.
And the first column
up to the n-1, that's
the one inconvenient spot
in electrical engineering.
All these expressions
start at zero, no problem,
but they end at n-1.
Well, that's -- that's the
difficulty of Course 6.
So what's -- they're the powers
of a number that I'm going
to call W --
W squared, W cubed, W to the
-- now what is the W here?
What's the power?
This was the zeroes power,
first power, second power,
this will be n
minus first power.
That's the column.
What's the next column?
It's the powers of W squared, W
to the fourth, W to the sixth,
W to the two n-1.
And then more columns
and more columns
and more columns and
what's the last column?
It's the powers of --
let's see.
We -- actually, if we
look around rows, w-
this matrix is symmetric.
It's symmetric in the old
not quite perfect way,
not perfect because these
numbers are complex.
And so it's -- that
first row is all ones.
One W W squared up
to W to the n-1.
That's the last column is
the powers of W to the n-1,
so this guy matches that, and
finally we get W to something
here.
I guess we could actually figure
out what that something is.
What are the entries
of this matrix?
The i j entry of
this matrix are --
I going to -- are you going to
allow me to let i go from zero
to n minus one?
So i and g go from zero to n-1.
So the one -- the zero
zero entry is a one --
it's just this same W guy
to the power i times j.
Let's see.
I'm jumping into formulas
here and I have to tell you
what W is and then you know
everything about this matrix.
So W is the -- well,
shall we finish here?
What was this -- this is
the (n-1) (n-1) entry.
This is W to the n-1 squared.
Everything's looking like a
mess here, because we have --
not too bad, because all
the entries are powers of W.
There -- none of them are zero.
This is a full matrix.
But W is a very special number.
W is the special number
whose n-th power is one.
In fact -- well, actually,
there are n numbers like that.
One of them is one, of course.
But the one we --
the W we want is --
the angle is two pi over n.
Is that what I mean?
n over two pi.
No, two pi over n.
W is E to the I and the
angle is two pi over n.
Right.
Where is this W in
the complex plane?
It's -- it's on the
unit circle, right?
This is -- it's the cosine
of two pi over n plus I times
the sine of two pi over n.
But actually, forget this.
It's never good to work with
the real and imaginary parts,
the rectangular coordinates,
when we're taking powers.
To take that to the tenth power,
we can't see what we're doing.
To take this form
to the tenth power,
we see immediately
what we're doing.
It would be e to
the i 20 pi over n.
So when our matrix is full of
powers -- so it's this formula,
and where is this on
the complex plain?
Here are the real numbers,
here's the imaginary axis,
here's the unit
circle of radius one,
and this number is
on the unit circle
at this angle, which is one
n-th of the full way round.
So if I drew, for
example, n equals six,
this would be e to the
two pi, two pi over six,
it would be one sixth of the way
around, it would be 60 degrees.
And where is W squared?
So I -- my W is e to the two
pi I over six in this case,
in this six by -- for the
six by six Fourier transform,
it's totally constructed out
of this number and its powers.
So what are its powers?
Well, its powers are on
the unit circle, right?
Because when I square a
number, a complex number,
I square its absolute value,
which gives me one again.
All the powers have --
are on the unit circle.
And the -- the angle
gets doubled to a hundred
and twenty, so there's W
squared, there's W cubed,
there's W to the fourth, there's
W to the fifth and there is W
to the sixth, as we hoped, W to
the sixth coming back to one.
So those are the six --
can I say this on TV?
The six sixth roots
of one, and it's
this one, the primitive one we
say, the first one, which is W.
Okay, so what -- let
me change -- let me --
I said I would probably
switch to n equal four.
What's W for that?
It's the fourth root of one.
W to the fourth will be one.
W will be e to the two
pi i over four now.
What's that?
This is e to the i pi over two.
This is a quarter of the
way around the unit circle,
and that's exactly i, a
quarter of the way around.
And sure enough, the
powers are i, i squared,
which is minus
one, i cubed, which
is minus i and finally i to
the fourth which is one, right.
So there's W, W squared, W
cubed, W to the fourth --
I'm really ready to
write down this Fourier
matrix for the
four by four case,
just so we see that clearly.
Let me do it here.
F4 is -- all right, one one one
one one one one W -- it's I.
I squared.
That's minus one.
i cubed is minus i.
I'll -- I could write
i squared and i cubed.
Why don't I, just so we
see the pattern for sure.
i squared, i cubed, i squared,
i cubed, i fourth, i sixth --
i fourth, i sixth and i ninth.
You see the exponents
fall in this nice --
the exponent is the row number
times the column number,
always starting at zero.
Okay.
And now I can put in those
numbers if you like --
one one one one, one i minus
one minus i, one minus one,
one minus one and one
minus i minus one i.
No.
Yes.
Right.
What's -- why do I think
that matrix is so remarkable?
It's the four by four matrix
that comes into the four point
Fourier transform.
When we want to find the Fourier
transform, the four point
Fourier transform of a
vector with four components,
we want to multiply
by this F4 or we
want to multiply by F4 inverse.
One way we're taking
the transform,
one way we're taking
the inverse transform.
Actually, they're so close that
it's easy to confuse the two.
The inverse of this matrix
will be a nice matrix also.
So -- and that's, of
course, what makes it --
that -- I guess
Fourier knew that.
He knew the inverse
of this matrix.
A- as you'll see, it just comes
from the fact that the columns
are orthogonal --
from the fact that the
columns are orthogonal,
we will quickly figure
out what is the inverse.
What Fourier didn't
know -- didn't notice --
I think Gauss noticed it but
didn't make a point of it
and then it turned
out to be really
important was the fact that this
matrix is so special that you
can break it up into nice pieces
with lots of zeroes, factors
that have lots of
zeroes and multiply
by it or by its inverse
very, very fast.
Okay.
But how did it get into
this lecture first?
Because the columns
are orthogonal.
Can I just check that the
columns of this matrix
are orthogonal?
So the inner product of
that column with that column
is zero.
The inner product of column
one with column three is zero.
How about the inner
product of two and four?
Can I take the inner product
of column two with column four?
Or even the inner product of two
with three, let's -- let's see,
does that --
let me do two and
four.
Okay.
What -- oh, I see, yes, hmm.
Hmm.
Let's see, I believe that those
two columns are orthogonal.
So let me take their inner
product and hope to get zero.
Okay, now if you hadn't
listened to the first half
of this lecture, when you
took the inner product of that
with that, you would have
multiplied one by one,
i by minus i, and that
would have given you one,
minus one by minus one
would have given you
another one minus I by I would
have been minus I squared,
that's another one.
So do I conclude that the
inner product of columns --
I said columns two
and four, that's
because I forgot those
are columns one and three.
I'm interested in
their inner product
and I'm hoping it's zero, but
it doesn't look like zero.
Nevertheless, it is zero.
Those columns are perpendicular.
Why?
Because the inner product --
we conjugate.
Do you remember that the --
one of the vectors in the inner
product has to get conjugated.
So when I conjugated, it
changes that i to a minus i,
changes this to a plus
i, changes those --
that second sine and that
fourth sine and I do get zero.
So those columns are orthogonal.
So columns are orthogonal.
They're not quite orthonormal.
But I could fix that easily.
They -- all those
columns have length two.
Length squared is four, like
this -- the four I had there --
this length squared, one plus
-- one squared one squared one
squared one squared is
four, square root is two --
so if I really wanted them --
suppose I really wanted to fix
life perfectly, I
could divide by two,
and now I have columns that
are actually orthonormal.
So what?
So I can invert
right away, right?
O- orthonormal columns means --
now I'm keeping this one half
in here for the moment --
c- means F4 Hermitian,
can I use that,
conjugate transpose times F4 is
i.
So I see what the inverse is.
The inverse of F4 is
-- it's just like an --
an orthogonal matrix.
The inverse is the transpose
-- here the inverse is
the conjugate transpose.
So, fine.
That -- that tells me that
anything good that I learn
about F4 I'll know the same --
I'll know a similar
fact about its inverse,
because its inverse is just
its conjugate transpose.
Okay, now -- so what's good?
Well, first, the
columns are orthogonal.
That's a key fact, then.
That's the thing that
makes the inverse easy.
But what property is it that
leads to the fast Fourier
transform?
So now I'm going to talk,
in these last minutes,
about the fast
Fourier transform.
What -- here's the idea.
F6, our six by six
matrix, will c-
there's a neat connection
to F3, half as big.
There's a connection
of F8 to F4.
of F(64) to F(32).
Shall I write down what
that connection is?
What's the connection
of F(64) to F(32)?
So F(64) is a 64 by
64 matrix whose W
is the 64th root of one.
So it's one 64th of
the way round in F(64).
And it -- do- and F(32)
is a 32 by 32 matrix.
Remember, they're
different sizes.
And the W in that 32 by 32
matrix is the 32nd root of one,
which is twice as far -- that
-- you sh- see that key point --
that's the -- that's how 32
and 64 are connected in the Ws.
The W for 64 is one
64th of the way --
so all I'm saying is
that if I square the W --
W(64), that's what I'm using
for the one over -- the --
W sixty f- this Wn is either
the i two pi over n --
so W(64) is one 64th
of the way around it.
When I square that,
what do I get but W(32)?
Right?
If I square this matrix,
I double the angle --
if I square this number, I
double the angle, I get, the --
the W(32).
So somehow there's
a little hope here
to connect F(64) with F(32).
And here's the connection.
Okay.
Let me -- let me go back, --
yes, let me --
I'll do it here.
Here's the connection.
F(64).
The 64 by 64 Fourier
matrix is connected
to two copies of F(32).
Let me leave a little
space for the connection.
So this is 64 by 64.
Here's a matrix
of that same size,
because it's got two copies of
F(32) and two zero matrixes.
Those zero matrixes are the key,
because when I multiply by this
matrix, just as it is, regular
multiplication, I would take --
need 64 --
I would -- I would have 64
squared little multiplications
to do.
But this matrix is half zero.
Well, of course, the
two aren't equal.
I'm going to put an equals sign,
but there has to be some fix up
factors --
one there and one there --
to make it true.
The beauty is that these fix
up factors will be really --
almost all zeroes.
So that as soon as we
get this formula right,
we've got a great idea for
how to get from the sixty-
from the 64 squared calculations
-- so this original --
originally we have 64 squared
calculations from there,
but this one will give us
-- this is -- this will --
we don't need that many -- we
only need two times 32 squared,
because we've got that twice.
And -- plus the fix-up.
So I have to tell you what's
in this fix-up matrix.
The one on the right is
actually a permutation matrix,
a very simple odds and evens
permutation matrix, the --
ones show up --
I haven't put enough
ones, I really need a --
32 of these guys at --
double space and then --
you see it's -- it's
a permutation matrix.
What it does --
shall I call it P for
permutation matrix?
So what that P does when
it multiplies a vector,
it takes the odd -- the even
numbered components first
and then the odds.
You see this -- this one
skipping every time is going
to pick out x0, x2, x4, x6 and
then below that will come --
will pick out x1, x3, x5.
And of course, that can be
hard wired in the computer
to be instantaneous.
So that says -- so
far, what have we said?
We're saying that the 64 by
64 Fourier matrix is really
separated into -- separate
your vector into the odd --
into the even components
and the odd components,
then do a 32 size Fourier
transform onto those
separately, and then put
the pieces together again.
So the pieces -- putting them
together turns them out to be I
and a diagonal matrix
and I and a minus,
that same diagonal matrix.
So the fix-up cost is really
the cost of multiplying by D,
this diagonal matrix, because
there's essentially no cost
in --
in the I part or in
the permutation part,
so really it's -- the fix-up
cost is essentially because D
is diagonal --
is 32 multiplications.
That's the -- there
you're seeing --
of course we didn't check the
formula or we didn't even say
what D is yet, but I will --
this diagonal matrix
D is powers of W --
one W W squared down
to W to the 31st.
So you see that when I --
to do a multiplication by D,
I need to do 32 multiplications.
There they are.
Then -- but the other, the more
serious work is to do the F(32)
twice on the --
separately on the
even numbered and odd
numbered components,
so twice 32 squared.
So 64 squared is gone now.
And that's the new count.
Okay, great, but what next?
So that's -- I -- we
now have the key idea --
we would have to
check the algebra,
but it's just checking a lot of
sums that come out correctly.
This is right -- the right
way to see the fast Fourier
transform, or one
right way to see it.
Then you've got to see
what's the next idea.
The next idea is to
break the 32s down.
Break those 32s down.
So we have this factor,
and now we have the F(32),
but that breaks into
some guy here --
F thirty- F six- F(16) --
F(16).
Each -- each F(32) is breaking
into two copies of F(16),
and then we have a
permutation and then the --
so this is a -- like, this
was a 64 size permutation,
this is a 32 size permutation --
I guess I've got it twice.
So it's -- I'm --
I'm just using the same
idea recursively --
recursion is the key word --
that on each of those F(32)s --
so here's zero zero -- it's
just -- to get F(32) --
this is the odd
even permutations --
so you see, we're --
the combination of those
permutations, what's it doing?
This guy separates into odds
-- in -- into evens and odds,
and then this guy separates
the evens into the ones --
the numbers that are
mult- the even evens,
which means zero
four eight sixteen --
and even odds, which means
two, six, ten, fourteen --
and then odd evens and odd odds.
You see, together these
permutations then break it --
break our vector down into
x, even even and three other
pieces.
Those are the four pieces
that separately get multiplied
by F(16) --
separately fixed up by these Is
and Ds and Is and minus Ds --
so this count is now reduced.
This count is now --
what's it reduced to?
So that's going to be gone,
because 32 squared -- that's --
that's the change
I'm making, right?
The 32 squared -- w- so -- so
it's this that's now reduced.
So I still have two times it,
but now what's 32 squared?
It's gone in favor of two
sixteen squareds plus sixteen.
That's -- and then the
original 32 to fix.
Maybe you see what's happening.
Even easier than this
formula is w- what's --
when I do the recursion
more and more times,
I get simpler and simpler
factors in the middle.
Eventually I'll be down
to two point or one point
Fourier transforms.
But I get more and more
factors piling up on the right
and left.
On the right, I'm just
getting permutation
matrixes.
On the left, I'm getting
these guys, these Is and Ds,
so that there was
a 32 there and --
each one of these is costing 32.
Each one of those is costing
And how many will there be?
So you see the 32
for this original fix
up, because D had 32
numbers, 32 for this next fix
up, because D has
16 and 16 more.
I keep going.
So the count in the
middle goes down to zip,
but these fix up counts
are all that I'm left with,
and how many factors -- how many
fix-ups have I got -- log in --
from 64, one step to 32, one
step to 16, one step to eight,
four, two and one.
Six steps.
So I have six fix-up --
six fix up factors.
Finally I get to six times
the That's my final count.
Instead of 64 squared, this is
log to the base two of 64 times
64 --
actually, half of 64.
So actually, the final count is
n log to the base two of n --
that's the 32 --
a half.
So can I put a box
around that wonderful,
extremely important and
satisfying conclusion --
that the fast Fourier transform
multiplies by an n by n matrix,
but it does it not in n
squared steps, but in one
half n log n steps.
And if we just --
complete by doing a
count, let's suppose --
suppose -- a typical
case would be two to the
tenth.
Now n squared is
bigger than a million.
So it's a thousand twenty four
times a thousand twenty four.
But what is n --
what is one half --
what is the new count,
done the right way?
It's n -- the thousand
twenty four times one half,
and what's the logarithm?
It's ten.
So times ten over two.
So it's five times -- it's five
times a thousand twenty four,
where this one was a thousand
twenty four times a thousand
twenty four.
We've reduced the calculation
by a factor of 200 just
by factoring the
matrix properly.
This was a thousand times n,
we're now down to five times n.
So we can do 200
Fourier transforms,
where before we
could do one, and
in real scientific calculations
where Fourier transforms are
happening all the
time, we're saving
a factor of in one
of the major steps
of modern scientific computing.
So that's the idea of the
fast Fourier transform,
and you see the
whole thing hinged
on being a special matrix
with orthonormal columns.
Okay, that's actually
it for complex numbers.
I'm back next time really to --
to real numbers,
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and the key idea of
positive definite matrixes
is going to show up.
What's a positive
definite matrix?
And it's terrific
that this course
is going to reach
positive definiteness,
because those are
the matrixes that you
see the most in applications.
Okay, see you next time.
Thanks.